fueron 61 votos a favor 36 en contra en
la cámara alta para codificar Es decir
para proteger el derecho Federal de los
estadounidenses a casarse las personas
del mismo sexo puedan casarse también se
aprobó el derecho a que personas de
razas de diferentes también puedan
casarse cuando lo deseen estas según
analistas una jugada que hacen los
demócratas Aprovechando que todavía
tienen mayoría tanto en cámara baja como
en cámara alta para poder pasar este
tipo de leyes que ya el presidente
Vallejo que apenas le llegara su
escritorio la firmaría republicanos
reaccionaron diciendo que pues no era
necesario pasar este tipo de leyes sin
embargo después de la decisión de la
Corte Suprema de Justicia este verano de
desconecer El derecho al aborto a nivel
nacional los demócratas han querido
tomar este tipo de medidas para proteger
derechos que según ellos son
fundamentales como el derecho al
matrimonio de el mismo sexo
Cristóbal también fue muy importante hoy
en Estados Unidos esa decisión de un
Jurado Federal que declaró culpable de
Conspiración para cometer se edición al
fundador del grupo de extrema derecha of
keepers por su papel en el asalto al
Capitolio que recordemos ocurrió el 6 de
enero del 2021 que sigue entonces en
este caso y qué repercusiones traerá
Sí pues se trata de stewards y Kelly mix
fundadores y líderes de esta milicia
Armada llamada keepers que pues fueron
hallados culpables ya por el Jurado de
sedición de Conspiración sediciosa esto
después de que se les hallara y se
tuviera las pruebas suficientes que
hemos que demuestran que estas dos
personas y su grupo y su milicia Armada
se armaron Y planearon de forma violenta
interrumpir el proceso de certificación
electoral de El 2021 el 6 de enero
precisamente del 2021 cuando pues se
simpatizantes de Donald Trump Se tomaron
el Capitolio y trataron de interrumpir
esta certificación electoral estas
personas pueden enfrentar hasta 20 años
de cárcel sin embargo Pues analistas
dicen que no va no van a enfrentar
tantos años en la cárcel por pues
vías legales que van
los abogados de estas personas y pues
obviamente esto ha generado bastante
bastante reacciones teniendo en cuenta
que es la primera vez que se haya
culpable de Conspiración sediciosa a
personas relacionadas con lo que pasó el
6 de enero del 2021 cuando se tomaron el
ca